et on va voir ce qu'en pense notre
second invité politiquement j'entends
l'année donc merci beaucoup d'être avec
vous ferez partie de ces nouveaux
députés la france insoumise qui vont
donc entrer à l'assemblée nationale vous
avez utilisé dans le val d'oise avec
plus de 63% des voix vous êtes également
coresponsable des élections législatives
à la france est soumise 72 députés pour
la france insoumise c'est loin derrière
le groupe du rassemblement national par
exemple est-ce que c'est un pari raté
pour vous non ce qui me rend une
réussite nous presque quadrupler le
nombre de nos parlementaires on est
lundi matin nous verrons dans quelques
jours et jusqu'au dépôt de la liste des
groupes combien nous serons dans ce goût
mais c'est une réussite considérable
avec des profils vous le verrez nouveau
des gens qui incarnent le peuple
français tel qu'il est aujourd'hui des
ouvriers et des ouvrières des salariés
rachel quétier bien sûr laurent
alexandre ouvriers de la métallurgie
sébastien des logos ancien chauffeur de
taxi ce sont ces personnalités qui vont
porter les mesures que nous défendions
pendant la campagne législative et et
qui les porteront comme l'ont fait les
dix sept parlementaires insoumis dans
l'assemblée de façon sonore et
convaincante pour essayer de faire
gagner nos propositions et répondre à la
crise sociale écologie extrêmement vives
qui frappe aujourd'hui une part
croissante des français comment est ce
que vous comptez pezade peser dans le
débat politique nos positions sonore
comme vous disiez ou éventuellement
constructive au coup par coup en tout
cas une opposition cohérente organisé
résolu qui a beaucoup préparer son
arrivée dans l'assemblée nationale ce
qui nous distingue peut-être de
l'ensemble des autres groupes qui vont
siéger dès demain dès après demain c'est
que nous nous sommes réunis là nul ce
autour d'un programme de 650 mesure je
veux le rappeler mais vous êtes dans
l'opposition alors nous sommes dans
l'opposition mais il n'y a pas de
majorité aujourd'hui dans cette
assemblée il ya une majorité très très
relative pour le président de la
république la république en marche et
une déroute pour le pouvoir en place il
perdre 150 députés par rapport à 2010
est froid ministre battu l'ensemble du
dispositif parlementaire de la macro ni
est à terre les chars ferrand battu
président de l'assemblée nationale
sortant le président du groupe b battu
le premier questeur questeurs et battu
donc tout cet édifice est à terre et à
nous donc de faire avancer nos
propositions nous l'avions fait dans la
mandature précédente le groupe
parlementaire de la france insoumise
avait rédigé un nombre considérable de
propositions de loi et porté un nombre
considérable d'amendements nous le
ferons nous serons premier proposant et
premier opposant à nouveau face à une
politique très dure qu emmanuel macron
prépare la retraite à 65 ans est sans
doute une coalition nous verrons avec la
droite ou l'extrême droite parce que
j'ai entendu hier monsieur dupont
moretti évoqué la possibilité d'avancer
avec le rassemblement national en tout
cas ne voulons pas exprimer avec n'était
fermeté une coupure avec l'extrême
droite ce qui d'ailleurs s'inscrit dans
la suite de la compagnie
opposant claire rassemblant sa liste upa
lire sur les plateaux juste la france
insoumise alors vous visez évidemment la
majorité ou viser le fait que jean luc
mélenchon cela matignon puis vous visez
le fait d'être le premier groupe
d'opposition aujourd'hui n'être ni l'un
ni l'autre est ce que c'est un coup dur
pour vous que le rassemblement national
pas devant vous à l'assemblée c'est un
péril pour notre démocratie mais c'est
surtout le résultat de la campagne qui a
mené la macro ni pendant ce mois ci à
qui se sont ils attaquent et désignant
les dangers de la république le chaos à
venir à nous la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale et à l'heure de la
vérité au soir du premier tour alors que
nous étions qualifiés dans 62
circonscription face au rassemblement
national dont combien les candidats de
la réplique en marche ont-ils pris leurs
responsabilités et appelé à défaire
semblement nationale et la majorité
présidentielle est exactement la même
chose que la majorité par asus
vous l'avons dit ça avec clarté et
d'ailleurs dès le soir du premier tour
de l'élection des présidents je permets
de vous dire que c'est faux c'est
inexact il y à une proportion
considérable des candidats défaits de la
république de la réplique aux matches
qui n'ont apporté aucune consigne qui
n'ont pas dit pas une voix pour la
nationale qui parfois ont appelé à voter
blanc eh bien il porte une ils ont ils
ont joué
en ce moment de gravité avec le feu eh
bien ils sont responsables premier
comptable deux sets
6-2 en une triangulaire dans nos
circonscriptions leur assemblée
nationale était arrivé en temps tu
écoutais l'art est plus qu un marché
maintenu aussi dans certaines
triangulaire nos candidats partout ont
pris des positions très claires et vous
connaissez la nôtre par une voix pour
leur assemblée nationale nous l'avons
dit et répété la réplique en marche on
ne l'a pas fait elle n'a pas été à la
hauteur elle des enjeux et au fond de la
préservation de la rive du goût seront
aussi un rempart face à l'extrême droite
et dans ces derniers mois nous l'avons
fait reculer dans le débat d'idées dans
la confrontation des arguments et
dépositions nous serons là à l'assemblée
nationale pour nous opposer au camp de
la haine de la haine des musulmans dont
on sait qu'ils qui cherche aujourd'hui à
diviser les français plutôt qu'à
répondre à leurs aspirations juste le
rassemblement national est aujourd'hui
le premier parti d'opposition à
l'assemblée vous revendiquez malgré tout
la présidence de la commission des
finances qui revient traditionnellement
à ce premier parti de garazi dur à 150
députés de la nuque c'est toujours plus
que 89 dur assemblée nationale vous me
l'accorderez sauf que là n'est pas un
parti mais la nuque sera un intergroupe
mais si vous allez décider de ne pas
siéger en quatre groupes différents mais
de siéger en un groupe unique justement
pour être plus fort encore assez minces
nous allons envisager toutes les
hypothèses et nous compris ab toutes les
hypothèses sont intellectuellement
stimulante et doivent être envisagées on
est lundi matin encore une fois il faut
nous laisser le temps de réunir et
d'échanger mai à 10 heures il a été acté
avant les élections que chaque perte
représente delà du port et son groupe à
l'assemblée exactement ça c'est plus
aussi clair aujourd'hui c'est tout à
fait clair et soyons prudents parce que
ce matin ça c'est clair mais je le redis
il y a vingt divers gauche il y a dans
votre infographie d autres il ya
beaucoup de candidats qui sont
estampillés aujourd'hui régionaliste
dans les outre mer qui pourront siéger
peut-être qu'ils seront sans doute au
sein de la nuque peut être dans le
groupe france a soumises nous verrons
donc je vous invitais à attendre à
patienter encore quelques jours on le
sait en a une semaine pour déposer la
composition des eaux
les communistes qui sont critiques hier
encore vis-à-vis de jean-luc mélenchon
et la france insoumise que dit vous êtes
les candidats les candidats des villes
et pas les candidats de la ruralité au
fabien roussel le plus total bientôt sa
liste je ne suis pas sûr que ce
serait les communistes s'exprimeront
mais j'ai entendu d'autres ou hamoir au
sein du parti communiste dire autre
chose vous saviez vous l'avez observé
ces derniers mois fabien roussel était
décalée par rapport à notre campagne nos
stratégies dont je le redit qu'elle a
parfaitement fonctionné au vu du nombre
de parlementaires qu'elle envoie à
l'assemblée nationale dans un contexte
inédit tôt que moi je sais l'aspiration
d'un grand nombre de communistes
parlementaires communistes à poursuivre
mais qui n'était pas en mesure de faire
un groupe aujourd'hui tout seul est ce
que vous les appelez à faire un groupe
qu'on ait la france a son idée est ce
que vous pensez qu'ils pourront suivre
écoutez vous l'avez il y aura le
principe tout d'un interview pas été a
été posée maintenant il ya quelques
jours pour constituer les différents
vous pouvez vous répondre sur le fond
nous marquons deux belles victoires dans
la ruralité quand vous voyez que en
haute vienne sur les trois
circonscriptions les trois seront de la
nuque quand vous voyez que nous gagnons
dans le grand sud ouest dans un grand
nombre de territoires nous sommes ancrés
dans la ruralité autant que dans les
quartiers populaires dans les centres
métropolitains c'est c'est à dire que
nous formons une coalition dont la
diffusion électorale montre qu'elle elle
joue pour un jour gouverner ce pays ce
groupe parlementaire ces groupes
parlementaires vont préparer l'exercice
du pouvoir
pour être en situation de l'exercer le
premier test qui va arrive à l'assemblée
va être consacré au pouvoir d'achat
c'est quelque chose de très attendue par
les français
revalorisation des retraites du rsa des
gel du point d'indicé des fonctionnaires
bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz
électricité vous voterez pour ou contre
attendre d'abord lire ce projet de loi
on connaît les mesures restent ont
annoncé depuis longtemps les annonces de
ce gouvernement et dans l'état on en
reste
insuffisant la gravité de la situation
est extrêmement grave il pourrait se
produire cet été dans ce pays une crise
humanitaire des millions de personnes
sont en train de sombrer dans la
pauvreté ils sont pris à la gorge par
l'envolée des prix dans le glocal en
l'absence de majorité absolue majorité
présentielle a besoin d'autres
sur cette situation gravissime les
conséquences de la canicule les
conséquence de l'affaiblissement de
l'hôpital public et de services
d'urgence qui vont nous le dit ont fermé
cet été cette situation est extrêmement
grave elle appelle un plan d'urgence non
pas des corrections d'ailleurs
correction de la politique du précédent
quinquennat qui n'est pas qu'ils
prennent en partie responsable de cette
situation mais c'est plus que des
corrections qu'il faut il faut tout
changer c'est ce que nous avons proposé
dans cette campagne c'est ce que nous
allons continuer à proposer dans
l'assemblée en proposant par amendement
par toutes les voies qui nous
permettront des mesures répondant aux
besoins des français il faut entendre
cette situation d'urgence sociale en
particulier j insiste dans laquelle ils
sont il se passe quelque chose en france
avec des gens qui tombent je l' ai vu
dans cette campagne qui tombe dans une
pauvreté terrible il faut des mesures à
la hauteur de cette situation peut très
vite une avant de conclure l'interview
au matin panneau était la présidente du
groupe la france a soumis jusqu'à
présent à l'assemblée nationale vous
souhaitez qu'elle soit réélu c'est la
candidate naturelle trois excellents de
présidente et lyon tout à fait qualifié
pour les crânes ou évidemment nous en
discuterons sont que nouveaux
parlementaires et je crois qu'elle
ferait une deux parfait de présidente de
vous raser les mots il devrait y avoir
un discours de politique générale le 5
juillet à l'assemblée nationale est ce
que vous déposera une motion de censure
là encore nous allons tout étudier mais
qui va voter la confiance à elisabeth
bornes c'est plutôt à ce gouvernement
qu'il faut poser la question elle est
disqualifiée et lila souhaitait son
départ aujourd'hui je crois qu'elle doit
partir elle doit partir tirer les
conséquences de ce de cette déroute de
ce désastre cette raclée électorale que
la république en marche bien vient
d'enregistrer elle n'est pas en
situation de gouverner le pays alors
elle doit prendre et qui pour la
remplacer mais ça c'est la question
orale à la pause et nos institutions la
vème république nous en subissons les
conséquences aujourd'hui ce matin vont
donner probablement à cronat peintre a
donné des gages à la droite et ça c'est
à lui de voir c'est à lui de ces jeunes
je vais pas répondre à sa place il est
donc d'une grande difficulté politique
il va être peut-être en effet dépendant
d'un parti qui lui a vu ses résultats
est en recul ce parti s'il y assad
paradoxal les forces qui naissent
quittera vu l'aspiration des français
celle de la nuque ne sont pas encore
majoritaires mais elle se prépare à
gouverner merci paul vannier merci
beaucoup d'avoir est notre invité vous
ferez votre entrée donc dans cette
nouvelle assemblée merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]